all right jose jose uh where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
i grew up in boyle heights right here uh
right here close to
downtown eastern east yeah and uh tell
me about your childhood you had both
your parents when you were young
yeah i had both of my parents uh i i
still have my parents um
they're uh you know they've been
together for for quite some time and uh
you know i got a big family you know 10
there's 10 of us
in my family you know i'm i'm the pretty
much the middle child
how would you just describe your
childhood oh
you know my my father's kind of pretty
pretty straight you know you know he's
uh
he believes in like a hard work and uh
you know just uh
you know doing the right thing you know
i just you know somewhere along that
line you know just uh
you know i just kind of felt like you
know a little
kind of like left out because you know
so many kids you know i mean i didn't
understand that back then
you know but you know as i'm a little
older i understand you know
you know how that came about you know
but
you know i just um yeah i i believe that
kind of affected me in a way to you know
where i started
you know going out you know and hanging
out on the streets and uh
you know you know finding like you know
like a family on the outside you know
what kind of kid were you in like in
high school as a teenager
oh as a teenager i was i was already
involved in gangs in the gang you know
you know um i got involved in again at a
very young age you know about
14 years old you know and um you know
pretty much in high school i was just
like
you know i already just didn't care more
about you know
you know doing the right thing you know
at the time because you know i already
had
caught involved in this gang and uh you
know just um
you know i just i i just that became my
family you know
yeah i hear that all the time yeah yeah
it becomes your family yeah and you know
so i just saw
you know i just that's that's it became
my family so i just like you know
do what they did you know was it was it
peer pressure or was it
uh i don't know not really just what all
the kids were doing not really
yeah just what everybody was in the
neighborhood was doing i mean it was it
was a thing to do back then you know
you know you know everybody everybody i
knew it was
involved in you know something you know
i mean you know
and then uh so after school was done
what
would you do with yourself well after
school was then i
entered and there was no after school
for me because i was i already
had i already went to jail when i was in
high school you know um at the ninth
grade i
i i ended up catching a uh
robbery and uh they sent me to do in a
hall i went to
i went to doing junior hall and um you
know i ended up being a year and a half
and uh you know why they only gave me
like
they only really gave me 10 months but
you know and doing a house
it's it's kind of like a different story
you know
is still like gang banging and all that
so
you know you're always fighting and you
know you're always always giving you
more time and more time and more time
you know just uh you know that's just
how it is in there you know
did you finish high school i did not i
did not finish high school you know i
was
i was i mean i why when i was when i was
uh
when i was you know in junior high and
all that you know and even in high
school
i would get good grades and all that but
i just
my mind was just somewhere else already
you know i mean my mind was not on just
uh
you know finishing school and you know
trying to do the right thing i was
already caught up in
other things you know with you know that
were outside of school you know yeah
when you're
your gang life started it was it was
more standard things and then then it
escalated
after that yeah you know it was first it
was you know just hanging out and you
know just um
and stuff like that you know just
tagging on walls and stuff and uh you
know um
you know getting into fights and all
that then just you know just got it just
got worse and worse you know it just got
became
became more and more and you know to me
it was just like that's that's that's
what
that's what i had to do you know i mean
that's that was just it just became a
lifestyle you know i mean it just
you know that was just the thing to do i
was nothing there wasn't really no
thought
thought into it you know just when
something happened we just did it you
know
and then you just took care of it you
know so it escalated at some point what
age was it where it got heavier
well i see about um
when i turned about 17 that's when it
started getting real heavy you know uh
you know you know going you know we
couldn't around that time when i was
growing up we really couldn't go nowhere
because it was
it was everywhere you know it was it was
it was it was
it was a it was like you know it's
pretty
it was pretty rough you know i mean
everybody everybody you know wherever
you went you got you got hit up by other
gangs you know
you know either you got you got into a
fire you got stabbed you got shot you
know i mean
and that's how i became you know and you
know i i got
you know i i got shot a couple of times
and you know
you know i'm a thousand times you know
five thousand fights and stuff
you know and you know it just became
more and more you know then you know
you know and then when when that happens
you know you you know they come and you
know
do something new you gotta eat you know
our thing was just to go right back and
retaliate you know
you know so it just you know that's
that's just how it was you know it just
became
like natural you know yeah do you recall
your very first time
being asked to put a hit out on somebody
um
mostly mostly that is uh um
when i when i got involved like that
that
that i was i was in prison so that
that that kind of uh that's when i
started doing something like that you
know i just you know uh
you know somebody was came on the yard
that wasn't good you know
you know uh you know just had you know
we got you know a lot of times they
would ask we want to do it i
you know i mean just wanted to make my
name a thing for myself i i
you know i raised my hand you know i
mean you know me you know there's a
couple other guys who go with me you
know but
so it like builds your reputation is it
yeah you know you you make a name for
yourself you know i
you know as long as you see right you
know what i mean you know
you know once you once you start you
know
for example say like snitch or something
then you know you're no good you know i
mean
right yeah and so it started in prison
and then yeah most most most of the
things i've done in that
in that in that sense is we're in prison
yeah you know i i'll hear
you know i've done some things but you
know i i never
took a stick around to find out what
really happened i mean
you know i just uh they just did it and
took off you know i mean
you know you know i can't that was just
the way to do things and this could have
happened anywhere
arizona texas northern california we're
not going to be
specific about where it was going on
yeah you know i just this is happening
you know
you know yeah whatever happened it
happened you know yeah i don't want to
get into details
um what
how many times do you think something
like this well i know that in prison
there was at least three of them
you know i just saw you know there was a
there was a
uh you know rapist uh child molester guy
in the yard
when took care of it yeah you know i i
have you know i
i for me it's somebody that doesn't is
not right a lot of people share that
same view you know i know
there's no no forgiveness for them yeah
there's really no forgiveness for that
you know what i mean
and you know the other ones you just saw
the other guys that just you know
messed up you know the old debts and you
know you know they you know they
already snitched or something right they
were snitches you know
and in prison you're you're not really
you don't have access to all the weapons
that you would want right
or not really but you know you you
you managed to make your progress you're
improvising you know
you know you you be when you're in
prison you become uh
it's like it's kind of like a network
you know you start you know get
information from other people and stuff
you start
learning how to do things that you know
you really don't know how to do you know
you just
you start you come you kind of become
creative
you know sort of sense you know you're
you're your first time what what
what weapon did you use uh i use a
homemade pretty knife
a homemade knife yeah it was just
you you alone or do you have no usually
it's like
like two two or three people yeah yeah
they want to
you know when something like that they
want to make sure the person's on you
know
yeah so you know it's you know
did you ever get caught uh not really
not really i mean i got caught once but
they couldn't prove it you know
um because there was i didn't have
nothing on me i didn't have no
blood no blood or nothing on me so i did
go
out you know they send you the whole and
all that and you go to committee and all
that but
you know it is you know they have to
still prove it i get caught you know
yeah you know uh so you never did time
for murders
no yeah and then outside of prison what
kind of things were
did you do well i i i used to do a lot
of robberies
um you know um some home invasions
and uh you know just uh
uh i have gotten uh i got
a kidnap i did get arrested for a chin
up that was my last term that i didn't
you know i
i've done a a ten year term you know
luckily i i got out because of the
circumstances that kidnap was you know
i didn't get i was trying they were
trying to give me 25 years to life but
you know the circumstances the way it
happened
you know i they offered me a deal and
they offered me a deal or take it to
trial and
if i lost i would have got life you know
but uh i
you know i i knew i knew the victim was
gonna go to trial and so
you know i i you know i thought you know
the right thing for me
was to do like take the deal you know so
i
i took the deal and uh you know i just
got you know but the thing is i got two
strikes now
you know just they saw you know so now
you have to walk a very straight yeah
yeah you walk a straight line you know
you just can't
i can't just you know i think about a
lot of things now you know i mean you
know
i you know sometimes some people say
something i you know i i want to just
snap but you know i think about you know
you know that
person really worth it now you know i
mean that you know now that i got kids
you know i just think of you know
you know i i you know am i going to
replace my life in
prison you know rather than be out here
you know for my kids you know and
i've been i've been quite some time and
you know i'm just
you know i just said that even i just
don't really want to be in there for the
rest of my life
yeah you know how do you older you know
i'm 48 years old
how has this affected your you
emotionally
to have done those kind of things oh
emotionally yes
you sleep over it yeah you know i just
said
i guess you say you know these uh you
know you guys are skeletons in the
closet you know i mean
you know they um you know they kind of
hunter you know i guess uh
you know after you know after doing some
things you know i started you know
you know picking up drugs and stuff you
know getting higher so i guess to just
forget
you know i know you know i never really
thought about it like that
at first but uh you know i you know i
could see it now you know sometimes you
know you just
you you you want to quiet quiet uh you
know
quiet that voice you know what i mean it
requires that i thought you know what i
mean and i you know
just i found i found that relief and
just getting high you know and um
you know just keeping it quiet you know
what i mean
you know and as a result that also
escalated you know i mean it just
became more and more and more and you
know it was your drug
heroin i i've done heroin and you know
um cocaine mostly
you know i you know i i was a kid i was
you know smoking pot drinking beer and
stuff you know i mean but
you know as that's after stuff started
really happening you know that's when
the
the harder jokes came in you know you
know because uh
you know that the part on the wheel and
just you know
you know and it also just you know made
me not care about what i did you know
yeah i just you know just
when it had to be done you just took
care of it you know what what's your
biggest regret in your life
oh my goodness regret is uh
man i really don't kind of live out of
regrets because i you know i
i kind of learned i i've i've i've come
to learn off
of what the things i've done you know
you know
and and uh i think i've come to make uh
you know better choices instead of just
acting my first thought you know i mean
yeah
you know and um so you know i mean as
far as regrets i you know i
i really can't think of a regret that
i've had you know
you know i just you know i
you know it was done was done you know i
mean i you know i can't at that time it
was just
i was just that was just the thing to do
you know i mean it was i had there was
no thought in it
you know uh what did what they one of
the things that
that that changed me it was uh you know
i
you know i had i had a guy i was married
for a while and um
you know i was trying to live in the
family life a little bit you know i said
these things on the side but you know
mostly
i i was with my family you know i know
you know i had a job and stuff and
but uh i ended up i ended up uh i ended
up running over this three-year-old boy
you know
and that you know i i wasn't drunk i was
in high i was nothing you know i mean i
was
you know i stopped you know i called i
called up i called the parameters i call
the cops and i mean you know
because to me i was like i i hit with my
own children you know i mean
i felt like that was one of my own kids
right there when i said you had an auto
accident
yeah i had an auto accident i i this
little kid was
riding a skateboard down his his
driveway with you know the sloped
driveway
and i guess at the same time he was i
was passing by he came down and i
i ran him over i didn't see him oh he
just came out of nowhere yeah he just
came out of nowhere and you know i i
felt i ran over something and um
you know um i didn't at first i thought
it was like a skateboard
or something you know but something in
my mind told me to stop and check you
know
and so i stopped i got off and i checked
and this little boy was
like lying in the street and uh man it's
just like
you know there was no thought of me
leaving and all that
you know running or nothing because you
know i i like i said before you know
i i don't believe in harming kids you
know i mean
you know to me that's wrong you know so
i stopped you know i was
you know i i you know i called
paramedics you know his family came out
you know i was like
you know i just it just became you know
it just kind of
it messed me up and it changed it kind
of changed me that's that's when uh
i kind of started changing you know i
was like you know i start
i really started thinking about life you
know what i mean you know i started
thinking about you know
you know other people's lives and stuff
you know you know i just you know i i
really not
i'm not you know i still talk to a lot
of friends and stuff you know i just
don't
you know i have to do nothing no more
you know i mean yeah you know i just you
know
i guess i've done my my my share of yes
you have
you know bad things you know so you know
i you know i you know i have friends
that you know have changed their lives
also you know i mean
you know they understand you know you
know they don't they don't they don't
judge me
you know for you know i you know
but um yeah so that when that accident
happened to me that you know that just
kind of messed me up and just
you know for a while i i got i got a
little bad and you know just
uh just didn't you know like
they you know to me they were telling me
oh they they ruled it as an accident but
to me i couldn't see it as an accident
you know i mean
you know i you know i i took a little
kid's life you know what i mean
you know and you know everybody saw me
oh it's an accident this is you know
but i just couldn't move i just couldn't
it kind of stuck with me for a while you
know
and you know for a while i was like
pretty much off balance and just
running like doing all kinds of crazy
stuff and you know just
you know but you know i kind of kind of
you know talked to some people and stuff
that you know you know
you know have been through similar
things and you know it's just kind of
you know made me
realize you know i mean you know there's
nothing i could have done you know i
mean no it sounds like it was
just yeah you just came out of nowhere
yeah i just you know i i just
i i did not see this kid at all you know
i mean just
it just you know happened i mean i would
i would have never
done that on purpose you know of course
not okay did you do do you see somehow
that there's some connection between
what you did maybe
earlier in your life and then that
somehow yeah
you know it's it's uh you know i
i thought i've thought about that you
know and uh you know i just
you know i think about it i mean you
know maybe it's just a way of you know
he gave me a wake-up call you know i
just uh
uh you know i also got i also got ran
over when i was three years old
yeah and you know i and you know i i you
know i i don't remember it but my
parents told me i got
i got ran over when i was three years
old and um you know
you know i used to think man why why why
did why did you why did i die when i was
speaking i mean why did
now those kids died you know well you
know um
you know i i guess now i you know i've
i've thought maybe you know like you
know there's a perp you know they're
purpose why i don't die you know you
know or something you know what i mean
you know i i have i don't know
you know the real reason but you know
there's
there might be i think about now you
know there might be something behind it
you know i mean you know
so yeah but what what what lesson have
you learned
through going through all this stuff in
your life
well what i learned is you know it's you
know
you know like life feels a little more
valuable than
to do just uh and just you know just
think you could do whatever you want and
you know you know just um
not really caring about anybody or
anything i mean it's just like
as i still i still have like trouble
like really caring about somebody that i
don't know
you know like you know it's like you
know i know and just what you know
whatever you know i mean but
you know i for me i i used to i used to
argue a lot with my my brothers and
stuff and
you know i just didn't care who i
already was back then i mean
and now you know i mean i'm more closer
to my family now and i guess that that
has woken me up you know i mean too
that's good too are you closer with your
kids now
yeah i'm really close to my kids that's
great yeah and so
you know i i talk to my kids about
everything you know i mean i tell i
yeah they ask me whatever they ask me
things you know and i tell them whatever
they want to know you know
so they know about that's fascinating
yeah they know about my past and you
know they know
they know you know i tell them because
you know the reason i tell them is you
know
this is um i want them to
understand you know you know about if
they
if they they go down the wrong way i
mean i i i believe for me is
you know me talking to them is is kind
of help because you know my
none of my kids are like me you know i
i'm grateful for that you know you know
my son's
you know has his own barber barbershop
and stuff and you know my daughter's
maybe another end and i have another
daughter has a eyelash just open up an
eyelash business
and stuff that's great and you know i
said you know not a baby but my
i have a 17 year old daughter that's my
baby you know but
you know i you know i i you know i guess
i guess me
uh you know they've seen they've seen me
out of their lives in and out of their
lives and stuff and you know i guess
me they see them seeing that they
realize you know i mean that's not
you know that's that's not what they
want for themselves you know
you know and me talking to them and
stuff you know just
letting him know that you know you know
there's there's consequences behind
everything you know
yeah so you know i like you know for
these something that i've done i never
got caught
you know i i i still pay for them you
know you know whether
i've done prison time or not i still pay
for them you know
you know you know mentally and stuff you
know i mean
you know you know sometimes i think you
know i'm always
sometimes i think something's gonna
happen to me i mean i always feel like
somebody's after me
right you know there's just is you know
you're always paying a price you know
what do what advice would you give to a
young man who's considering joining a
gang
well you know you know what i want to
see some people
you know when when uh when other people
were telling me when i was young
hey don't do that i do like you know i
was like man who are you just telling me
not what to do when you look at you you
know what i mean
you know so i mean like me saying that
it's like you know
now now i understand what you're talking
about you know i mean
sometimes you got to live and learn you
know and um
you know but my advice to somebody
that's young you know i mean you know
you know that if you're going to join a
gang be ready to be
be ready to be in prison all your life
be ready to be ready to be you know
you know hiding all your life be ready
to be watching your back all your life
you know be ready to just be ready at
all times you know what i mean because
you you're gonna be running you're gonna
be running you'll be hiding you're gonna
be
you know you're gonna be watching over
your back all the time and you know just
this is not this is not comfortable this
is not a comfortable way to live you
know i mean just
but um you know i just said you know
there's there's better ways to live you
know i mean
you know you know i i i thank god i've
i've gotten to learn to trade you know
and in some time that i was
i was married you know you know and
that that that now has helped me out you
know what are you doing for work now i'm
i'm a plumber i'm a plumber by trade you
know i went to school five years from
plumbing
yeah i worked for the union and um you
know
that kind of has helped me you know i
still you know would fall you know you
know
it's kind of i guess that's that kind of
has
really kept me from going from being
maybe just
you know ending up dead or
really doing life you know in prison
yeah you've had an interesting life yeah
so you know
i mean that's my advice to anybody who
wants to join again you know i mean
it's not you know
you can still have fun and and and not
be not watch
be watching all your back yeah so i mean
all right jose thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome i wish
you the best of luck
thank you thank you
you